we're asked to simplify the cube root of
eight a squared b to the fifth c to the
third power now the easiest way to
simplify a cubic radical like this we
have to find the the cube root is to
factor this this expression inside the
radical into things that are perfect
cubes and things that aren't and the
things that are perfect cubes we can
just take the cube roots of those and
then delete and then kind of take them
out of the radical and everything else
we can leave under it so first let's
just focus on the eight figure out if it
can be factored into a perfect cube or
maybe it's a perfect cube itself
eight is two times four
four is two times two so eight is two
times two times two or it's two to the
third two to the third is equal to eight
or
or we could say
or we could say that the cube root
of eight is equal to two so eight is
already a nice perfect cube so let's
worry about this other stuff over here
so let me rewrite the radical so let me
rewrite the radical over here i'll leave
the 8 the way it is because it's a nice
perfect cube already
i'll leave the 8 the way it is and then
let me focus well a squared i'm not
going to really be able to factor that
into kind of a to the third times
something else i mean i could if i
wanted to be really tricky but i'll just
leave it as a squared for now let me do
that in a different color so that's a
squared
a squared b to the fifth
b to the fifth i can write that as b to
the third power times b squared and that
way i have a perfect cube here and then
i have something that's not but this at
least i can take the cube root of and
then c to the third that's already a
perfect cube
c to the third the cube root of that
is c so times c to the third and so we
can rewrite this expression here just
reordering things a little bit this is
the same thing as the cube root of
8
that's the first term right there times
the cube root of b cubed
times the cube root
of
b cubed
times the cube root times the cube root
of c cubed
so so far i've taken care of that term
that term and that term and these are
all the ones that i can actually take
the cube root of then i can leave the
other two under this larger cube root so
times
times the cube root
times the cube root
of we have our a squared here and then
our b squared our a squared and then we
have a b squared right here now the cube
root of eight is two
cube root of b to the third is b let me
do the same colors makes it more
visually compelling cube root of c to
the third is c
and then this you can't really simplify
anymore i mean you could kind of play
around with it but it's about as
simplified as you can get for this cubic
radical or this cube root radical or
this third root depending how you view
it so times
the cube root
the cube root of
a squared b squared and we're done